so welcome again everyone to our well
well
like we will do like we did last last
week like combining the
intermediate and advanced class because
i just see
no point in really discussing deep chest
strategies when we have well the world
cup one of the two or three most
important
tournament in the world going and
especially since we are well
very now we are at the final stage after
today but we left last time i think it
was something like quarter finals like
when we when we
left last time it was just when
nakamura lost to kobold that was
actually the game that was i think
played the same day that we
that we actually
did last wednesday
and we had kamsky still in actually
great game beating my medal but you know
we'll start we finished with
the top american player being knocked
out so we have to continue with the
second top american
being knocked out and actually against
tomaszewski that by now we know he's out
of the tournament but
definitely one of the well probably the
big cinderella of this
uh tournament beating our younger world
number two player
beating mauro zevitch beating kamsky
just beating pretty much everyone
beating wesley saw before that
so this was played
this i believe is in the
quarter final right this was
this was kamsky tomaszewski and the
first game was actually a very quick
very quick draw tomaszewski was white
and was just tired of previous round
so no big surprise that they
played the ray lopez
tomaszewski is a very very classical
player so
expecting e5 from him and all those is
very logical the same from kamsky
castle and h3
like
all those moves h3
d3
a3a for all those
new moves
basically if you want to call them new
they are designed for one purpose what's
the purpose
why not c3 why why people don't play c3
so much the super classical way
which one
yeah and you know they just
went deep and deeper and deeper and into
the marshall and
it was pretty much impossible to find
anything that or at least many people
think just by
they not playing
not getting into the marshall anymore
like just amazing just not getting into
marshall anymore so
we see all those
anti-martial systems
coming on move eight sometimes we
already see them actually
d3 is becoming more popular
actually this move d3 is
useful
fighting against the berlin already
instead of going to one other
very frustrating opening for white just
d3
making effort to get something although
not really easy they play bishop c5 and
well if
e5 is one of the toughest toughest
openings out there i mean
in sicilian it's not like you can get
really advantage right i mean
but you say oh i can get advantage
against night of
not going to be that serious claim but
you get a lot a lot a lot of game right
i mean you can win you cannot
in e4e5 just getting a game is many
times the big problem
okay
something like the marshall
d5
capture capture
and
a4 of course after knight takes e5 i
don't i'm not 100 certain what they
would play here i think that 94 if i
remember okay is one of the main moves i
think it is the main move and just going
after the b shop on b3 and using the
long diagonal is
just for certain gives black enough
enough play
i mean there's a if if we have any
opening any questions about those lines
we can stop tiny bit and we can pull out
chess base but if we just want to see
the game and tiny get impression
that's what i'm tiny bit more for
so a4 was played
take take
knight before okay so first question
here is what's going to happen after f6
well what do we think will happen after
f6
because it's looks very very logical
move this f6
so
yes
yeah i mean if not 95
white gonna find himself in a big
trouble just one more for example let's
say that white plays the spectacular
king h1
which move should black play here i mean
black has a very strong move in this
position
really very strong which one would it be
principle achieving a lot of things the
way i see it i mean
nothing gigantic but just a good move
the way i see it
yes
jacob share with us
share with us
your if you have a game next week you
need you need to get all the energy and
fight so
here you know this position next week
one and a half one and a half you know
like the entire burden of the season is
on your shoulders
something
which one
c5 well saved by julian sitting next to
him yeah sifa is very good
because what what
little jacob okay so jacob was too
modest no we we take away knight a5 but
more importantly just
basic strategy actually there was a game
that
anand lost to caruana this year like few
months ago actually kiwanis said maybe
after it we can have a very quick one
just to see how that game went very
quick one
black has this mighty bishop
light color bishop
very very pretty one well if we can
accompany this bishop
by the pawns controlling dark squares
i don't know i think we'll be very happy
no
i mean so suddenly look what we have
here the bishop is controlling all the
light squares and the pawns are
controlling dark squares now black is
way way better
but like jacob mentioned before yeah of
course knight a5 will be played
this is just bad in
maybe just taking the knight c6
attacking the queen and the rook on a8
and if something like
this move how should i play him
take everything and then
how come
but then but then you know that that's
the part where i say the chess is a
little bit more science than philosophy
so
no you're right but i think white has a
very principle correct move
take the bishop all right good now what
no that's that's good we took the bishop
away agree this this should be played
most likely but now which move d4 d4
why why should you release the tension
here
because black would be happy d4 black
has big weakness and his pieces are the
queen is tiny bit far after take take
white is very happy i mean e6 is there
equal material queen f3 white is only
one playing here and totally totally for
free
this this the queen can come to g4
well i would not want to open the queen
side i don't want to exchange those
pieces
i i think i do not
so this this is the yf6 impossible
because if
f65 possible strategically black is much
better
so now you know i was analyzing this
position actually just a bit tiny bit
away actually the question from someone
quite strong like 2400 player he was
asking me what happened if take
and i just told him you know
i just play queen d5 and i just have
enough positional compensation the
bishops
i think after it computers say similar
things if here and then
i don't remember what i was thinking i i
not the computer my computer want i
think when i played this move
actually yes this threat kind of
annoying that take and c2 is vulnerable
always always c2 is a big
is a big weakness so
you white didn't want to get a martial
on doe a but he's getting marshall on
dolby
similar stuff
so take take
take
yeah and here
immediately is taking maybe
after take
i wonder if this is what
black would want it to go first of all
tiny bit exchange and maybe then take
maybe rook take like for example
because then
knight takes c2 doesn't come with
any threat there is no rook on a1 that
is tiny bit trapped like you know knight
takes c2 and the rook is in trouble so
it was really if white will give this
move he definitely doesn't want to have
a hook here that will be wasting lots of
time for him to move
okay so black took
of course the pawn has to take right
because this is actually costing a lot
of material on the spot
okay so basically we got
in whatever version
this position
and two pawns
two pawns now
this is really interesting
we we only we always know
about chess like the material part right
white is two pawns up
but this is a real you know i always
tell
let's say young students you know not
too strong that we analyze with
this is what real chess is about like
taking all the components that we have
materials space pieces activity king
safety
pawn structure you know all of them
throw them together and see what's
happening if one player has two pawns up
better structure safer king better
pieces okay the game is over there's
nothing to think about what is real
about chess this one player is two pawns
up
white
he has horrible structure
weak king and black pieces are more
active that's a real game of chess i
remember the computer was saying here
about white is up half a pawn which
means black compensation is equal to a
point and they have right he's down two
points two pawns two points but he's
just computers say only half a point
because of that much compensation
rookie 8
makes sense king g2 h6
yeah and here there was a very
very cool idea i think tomaszewski
played
played uh knight d5 okay we cannot say
it's illogical
but there are some other ideas in the
position actually quite a cool ones
anyone want to think about some suggest
some ideas
which move
no no but but
for white knight if he if white can play
knight e4 he will be the happiest dude
out there at least a in norway but it's
black to play
rookie five
i will take this knight
you will take this knight
then i will let's say play rook to e4
let's put it on the board
every piece that goes out of the board
little party for white right he's up to
pawns every piece that goes out less
attack for example this position
i think black is selling nothing
next move queen e2 bishop f4 g3
black is black is losing here just
resigning here i mean really two pawns
and
nothing no
white
black black has to keep the game
going he has to keep some
game if i remember okay this was a
really cool idea take take
what a bizarre pin
what a bizarre pin with the beautiful
threat of
knight a2
attacking the bishop and impossible to
defend the bishop on c1
i mean and this is amazing like
checkmate to the bishop kind of
amazing the bishop is trapped
so i think there were some lines like
queen going somewhere and
i don't remember exactly
this was one idea
taken queen to a1 but tomaszewski
okay was a bit afraid to go into
something like that so he played here
knight e4
attacking the rook that is on the wrong
spot if if right rook is on f1 i think
black is a bit in trouble but
the rook is a bit
on wrong spot
knight take now here is the question did
cansky really have to take there
yes c4 something
c4 if i yeah somehow
somehow i i think that this 95 was not
best i mean he had to
he had to take if i remember okay and
queen a1 but
yeah here interesting remember kanski
was casually was playing very very
decent chair i mean probably best chess
before this
this game and actually
okay i mean let's see if he would have
if he would have uh uh
beat tomaszewski
who tomaszewski got after it immediately
andrew
yeah kanski
kanski would have been a favorite
against andre kena i think the way he
played like that's really really
and he has no okay both american like
also nakamura was
was having very very okay
field with kobo
yeah i like c4 more i mean somehow to
give away this knight
i find it a bit scary a bit this knight
looks like just good defender out there
and if black wants to kick it okay let
him play a five which is tiny bit
weakening
it's a way another move it's tiny
take
c for now
yeah i'm not certain why you didn't play
c4 move earlier
c6
rook b3
is this more possible look a5
i mean i think we can maybe
go here
well actually i want to think a bit
maybe something like this check
and if king goes here
maybe knight here
just the pawns looks so ridiculously
weak
but maybe d4
and if here here okay i can take already
one pawn
it's not so horrible take one pawn and
then go back
it looks
just just by the look of it looks
somewhat
somewhat reasonable
but actually actually no i just i think
this is just a much better move of
course
just this double attack
yeah i mean actually white is the one
that should be
should be worried in this position
because the king is so weak
here is a big question
should white continue to play for a win
here
or should white think about making a
draw
making a door right okay we know that he
lost so we are super smart
but
i i think that you know obviously caskey
is very very strong and he quite
his position
was still okay a few moves after but
i think that he
and actually needs a clearly better
rapid player than tomaszewski
very decent
rapid rapid tournaments like it's a bit
tiny surprising but
yeah in blitz i think is definitely
weaker than many players
but in rapid actually
he won't mind tournament with youth
score a few years ago and
i think he should have just made well go
for a draw and
go
see after it
this was the critical position that
that he started going wrong okay
which move to play here for
white
right has one move to play here if he
wants if he has dreams about winning
here
so
yes any yes
default for certain
right you have to tiny bit get the hook
somewhere
so here here here
that that's the thing black just want to
attack the pawn
well you kind of cannot protect the pawn
right
king g2 will check
check you know
go here and so on so on you know just
dance around so the pawn on h3 cannot be
defended
but you have rookie three that that's
the big thing about d4
take take and now
pretty much on one move for black to
play very logically
you don't want to exchange rooks right
so
play this move
and this was the position that is very
critical i mean tomaszewski has five
minutes kamsky has three so
it's tiny bit roulette already like i
mean
okay then position is so
complicated actually like a lot of
calculations need needs here
that playing the next 10 moves is
completely different than playing 10
basic moves in an opening that will take
you a second or position that the
pattern is so clear
to me it was really interesting because
i was looking at this game and i thought
no i thought right what's better what
too i mean
i can tell you that i was smartest man
in the world and i knew that black is
okay or whatever but
it kind of looked like quite somewhat
better i mean the king looks safe and
extra pawn but it was interesting
actually to hire tomaszewski
saying that he thought white has no way
to play for a win here no the way the
game turned it was very is very correct
basically saying look
d b3
rook to a8 okay you want to go here and
here not very bad
d5
now he cannot he cannot actually do that
immediately of course because of
checkmate but that's the idea he wants
to have the rook somewhat active
and queen back to d7
and here tomaszewski said look white
king is weak
the h pawn is dangerous this this was
amazing to
to
feel how the danger how dangerous this
pawn is because you think the king is so
close
but
and white's extra pawn is meaningless
i mean
the timings couldn't be more identical
so it's this is not a factor here kanski
should have probably taken a drawing
okay looking at his face after the game
you know there is
nobody enjoys
losing especially not at this stage
especially not in this situation
but there are some situations that i
think i described it that kamsky beat
himself other than the opponent beat him
yeah i mean tomaszewski played excellent
but
kanski could have pretty much just
played logical simple here not
go for too much
this is where he started losing the game
rk6 is a good move just stopping
the pawn advancing
and the rook is gonna this is the rook
that's gonna win the game
b4
but what is this what and where is this
pawn going
well this is a pond it's very dangerous
super outside past pawn
queen d4 i think i think if i'm not
mistaken now he's already losing
i think so
yeah because now
those were two horrible horrible moves
because now how to stop really the pawn
that's the question i mean if the queen
goes to h4
how should white should black play here
okay
yeah actually this is just a simple one
i i was okay this is this is a very good
this is the best move or the easiest one
i actually wanted to show that i think
white king is very vulnerable just left
with with no defenders but this is a
this is of course the best move
just the pawn is going to be a queen
that's not really bad so how to stop
this spawn suddenly
kind of impossible
what what
by getting checkmated
yeah
so so actually what what should we have
played here i i don't know i mean i'm
you know part of it is that i have some
ideas about the games but i'm looking at
it pretty much like you just because i
think that's the the most
entertaining way you know like we are
both sharing and looking instead of
coming with
huge gigantic analysis and then it's
more like lecturing instead of analyzing
together
but what to play here
me
maybe queen before now
right
but if rookie 2 tiny bit scary
rook d4 queen 82 tiny bit scary
no white's position is no not so much
fun already maybe maybe maybe just like
f4 you know
let me play this f4 so the rook is alive
and then i can pull my king
this this i can this i can live with
f4 and i can pull my king this like i
think i can live with
queen queen g4 okay
okay you know everyone's happy
everyone's happy
unless i get checkmated they'll lose the
queen then i'm not happy
so this is
this is not so happy
this is not happy also
which one
rookie fall
yeah looking for i think i think you are
right
no but this king is so weak
huh
and if this for example you'll go here
okay this this this is okay
i mean i was looking for a second about
something like this but that's that's a
recipe for losing for black
yeah rookie 4 is an excellent move just
just stopping the pawn and
maybe getting the king whenever possible
to some safety if possible
makes sense
yeah i just remember that on move 35 36
it just
because now you just cannot lose the
game it's it's so easy actually to
underestimate this pawn because it looks
like the king is so close
so he played
king f1 and now for people that didn't
see the game for people that saw the
game shush for people they didn't see
the game i'll give you two
two minutes to think two three minutes
to think
i'll give you two minutes and 26 seconds
to think how to win here
so
and probably gonna win right
yeah
yeah there's going to be something i i
tiny totally agree with you i mean all
gonna cost the queen like probably this
is something like best
best version yeah i mean i mean
tomaszewski did it other way around
which is just kind of simpler i mean
that's totally the right idea totally
okay no this is winning
he plays he played this move he gave a
queen
for you you see
just just that he gave an extra one he
said give me one okay then take it
it's nice there right like
this it's yours back
yeah no okay one checkmate because of oh
my gosh that can be
not pleasant but
after all g6 not not very pretty yeah
actually if i remember okay i i think
this was like checkmating seven moves
something like
computer was so happy but yeah i i just
i just seen this this moment of the game
and one other before
and i know that this was around equalish
and suddenly after h3 maybe minus five
or so just winning
so
no not not an easy way to get out of the
world cup i mean a game that it was
clear that white was
you know
black was playing to equalize when he
had compensation black at no point was
pressing to check mate white he was two
pawns down
the maximum that he could get is one
point down with
a dangerous pawn
knowing kamsky here kind of blew it big
time
so this is the story of kamsky
well now we're gonna see the story of
the last year we know that is not a bad
one peter swiddler playing against
the player that is at the final no this
is amazing this system amazing he's at
the final
he won one game in a normal time control
one game in a normal time control is
down eight rating points
so it makes this performance like twenty
six fifty okay this this is grand master
performance i think something like that
a strong game master but not world cup
and he's going to play for
the world cup and that is andre king and
his amazing strategy is uh
okay i don't need to win on normal time
for this we have rapid we have blitz i
can play there and win it's not bad but
well we'll see how we did it to peter
yeah yeah he hasn't been playing amazing
chess in the last i don't know a few
months but
he's amazingly strong blitz player
amazingly clearly one of the best in the
world and
very strong
rapid player so but on the other hand
his opponent swiddler is
pretty much the same i mean i i think in
normal chess i think svidler is a
stronger player
but in rapid obliques unclear
so
what is this system you know i i like to
tiny bit discuss this well what does
this system tells an amateur that's
looking at the game
yes but
why is white playing it
controlling e4 no but but the big the
bigger
strategical view of that what is it the
biggest strategical view
to me
is saying dude
i'm just going to move the pieces to the
right squares i'm not going to do
anything fancy i'm going to get a decent
position healthy one push the clock hard
and fast and will play rapid well that's
that's not it's not a bad one i mean
there are many of the world best players
not everyone play
in blades like i don't know like
kasparov or
you know fisher okay fisher was
absolutely unbelievable to his
generation in
in blitz like i mean i remember some
tournaments i think in manhattan he won
like 22 and a half out of 23 or 24 like
i mean he was best player in the world
in chess by far but in blitz
it was several times by far at that time
but okay
you just want to get okay position
and not blonder
and get the game going and that's
exactly what he is doing look
okay does this seem solid enough for
white or should we put another two pawns
just to just to make it but it's not bad
i can tell you know in
in you know uh many many levels aren't
there i used to play quite a lot of time
was online for
icc the internet chess club
and when i played simon's it depends on
the mood if i wanted really to score
very high
i played those structures because there
are easiest and fastest structures to
play and if you're in a simul you can
produce a decent move within
two seconds
two seconds nothing nothing dramatically
is happening if i was more in the mood
of okay you know let's have fun then i
play d4 main lines e4 main lines you
know just
anything but
when you're playing for
world cup
you're playing rapid
white just wants to get a game and if he
gets a game with something tiny bit in
it he's going to be very very happy
take
take take it's interesting usually
usually white in those positions if
there were more pieces i think white
will take with the e pawn
when white stakes with the e pawn if
there are more pieces
usually it means that
he wants to open the e file
and he wants to
think about some way to attack black
but there are no there are no pieces on
the board to do that
so i thought that this is logical and we
have to give white
slight advantage here
why do we have to give white
advantage
well one tiny reason i mean it's not
really big one but one tiny reason why
is that
black's knight on a6 is a b it's not
pretty right if the knight was on c6
okay i think
no not really that much to discuss
queen e7 so the knight can come back
from before
castle castle
and he actually did it the other way i
thought that night before was also a
possibility
but maybe this one is better maybe night
before
it gets something like this and
not that a bit less easy
okay
okay all in all
kinda nothing
really big nothing
still tiny tiny better to play for white
but
i think just because of
this weakness the pawn is here so tiny
bit the squares are weakened
okay
basically somewhat more
space in the center if you want to put
it this way
queen b7 queen a3
by the way this is what
what's important you know
it's very very serious
the position is probably zero one but
those six minutes advantage
they already mean something okay maybe
not much but maybe they are another zero
one or another zero something
in none of the game you know uh we spoke
we will speak a lot about vashir
in the second part of of this uh world
cup review
when you see strong players
and you
see that they are constantly
ahead of the time in rapid in blitz it's
just they're very comfortable and
comfortable means a lot it's quite much
better here not at all
he feels more comfortable and he's
playing faster that's what you need to
do to play rapid very well
f5 okay was it necessary not clear but
okay he wants to control this square
okay
now here is an interesting moment
when i was looking at this game after
i was wondering i thought black has a
simple continuation in
in my view and
i have no idea what white is going to
show after it
well what what would make sense for you
just let's say just make it as simple as
possible to equalize completely on the
board what would it be
knight takes knight pawn take
nd5 i i totally agree when i was looking
at this this was my first thought i
think it's okay
because for example
if black would play i don't know okay
let's go again to our genius brilliant
moves
i don't know you know speaking about
some
some complications i'll play e d5
queen back
do you prefer to be white here when your
opponent has let's say eight minutes you
have 20
i i think it's it's it's risk-free for
white black king is weak d5 is weak f5
is weak
white might get a better structure not
clear how to defend all the pawns for
example maybe this move
i think black justin
no now maybe just trouble not not
unpleasant already right i mean
if here we first take with the check
so just d5 you know the less noise the
easier
and
what what for what for white in this
position
what does white have here
but how that's that's the thing because
because it can you cannot you know it
looks like technically it's putting
pressure on the c file but it's not
because whenever the rook moves roxy for
rook c2
i mean exchanging rules nothing nothing
nothing i mean this is
when i looked at that it's like as much
nothing as possible
yeah this to me okay but again
you know
people are i i said i started in a
negative approach about anderkin but
there is no negative approach if that's
not working for him
you know it's like
then great thing you know you you will
win the world cup and everyone will say
wow but he he didn't win one you know he
lost rating points he did okay great so
people will say you know at the end of
the day you know the buzzer you don't
really remember why someone won and if
he died no they played nasty nah they
did this that you remember the score
look
is
20 minutes 19 minutes versus eight the
position is equal but
he feels comfortable and he's in his
territory
you know like the world champion anand
kept his title in
wow they know those those rapid games so
night before
yeah i don't like this this way by
sevilla because
he played this
okay
so he's a pawn down
white
but
suddenly this king looks weak
this beautiful night
looks
tiny less beautiful
objectively the position is probably
okay for black i think computer was
saying it's okay but
i for certain would like to play this
and i don't like to give a pawn i don't
i don't really don't but
i like to play this with white ten
minutes more on the clock
black king is weak
white is playing with no risk at all
like zero i think
very easy for white to play
knight before
take take
queen f3
okay so this is the stretch right
a5
rookie six no just not pleasant to play
for black i mean what does he want to
check and take to start with i guess
right some
some things like that
something although we have to be careful
because is this really a threat by the
way
let's say we go here i just wonder if
this is a threat
because this is possible and then take
so i'm not i'm not totally certain this
is a
threat
it's not a threat right because i i
cannot see anything here for white
first of all okay swiddler pulled this
king immediately
maybe maybe same idea i mean just
something like this now this is this is
a very big one actually
no because this this attacking
everything
and the king cannot escape because of
queen who take a six i i play this move
of course a4 is a super random
meaningless move but i just want to
understand what's the threat always in
such position you should ask yourself
okay
what's my opponent want to do if i give
him if i just push the clock and do
nothing i think this is
this is a decent a decent threat
maybe also this one in some situations
this was played
queen g3 it's very strong move you know
he wants to take here
if this move okay queen g6 and take
this move is not working because off why
is this move not working
rookie 7 is not a bad one winning the
game immediately
right
yeah so so quite a lot of pressure you
know black
black is here
i mean he's probably gonna lose the pawn
now white is
quite clearly better here and
okay actually andrew king spent a lot of
time not surprisingly when he was a pawn
down
okay then then you really want to be
accurate because you don't want somehow
for the initiative to sleep and then you
find yeah you had initiative but now you
have a pawn down and
fighting for it
but
okay the winner of
previous world cup and always you know
an amazingly strong player in all those
things i mean andre king is his first
time being so
russian champion svidler six times so
played knight d5
i can tell you that i was looking at
this position and okay this was my first
instinct
and white is much better here but
yeah that's not the move that was played
this is the second best move but it's so
ridiculously wrong compared to the move
that was actually played
so what was played here
one one move
you beat him you killed him that was
played excellent job
very good resign
very good
just just
just just resigned
yeah that's that that was
that was very good
because whenever the knight is under
attack and if it goes
i said that now i forgot that
we we said we spoke before about the c5
in the previous game just to show the
bishops the light colors and the pawns
on the squares
queen f7 right right right right right
i i also when i looked at that the first
time that was also my idea and i
blundered it the second time but okay
rookie seven very good
you